welcome everybody to
gan theft auto what you see here is me
playing
inside of a neural networks environment
this neural network was trained by
watching a bot play grand theft auto 5
on this particular stretch of highway
learning how to generate new frames
from previous frames and player input
so every pixel you see here is generated
from a neural network while i play
while generating the visuals or just
improving them
is interesting too and there has been
some interesting work lately with neural
networks improving the visuals with
grand theft auto 5 in particular
in attempts to make it look more
photorealistic
this is something much more than that
the neural network in this case
is the entire game it's handling what
happens when you press a key
to turn left or right there are no rules
written here
by us or the original grand theft auto
engine
the neural network is controlling all of
this along with what happens when we try
to turn
into another car when we hit a wall or
what objects in the background should do
what the light reflections should do
it's doing all of this based on our
inputs
it's the visuals the controls the
physics
it's everything we are playing entirely
within a neural network's
representation of grand theft auto 5.
so we're used to seeing ai playing
within environments but here the ai
is the environment it's just a model
that we're running with python that
takes key presses from me
the player and outputs pixel values
we've also added on top some super
sampling to make things look a little
less pixelated than they are natively
so you can see the native in the kind of
bottom middle screen there
the other neat thing here is gan theft
auto runs pretty much on any machine
that does matrix math
and has a display hooked up it doesn't
really matter what your operating system
is or other underlying software
beyond a gpu acceleration so where did
this all come from this is a project of
daniel kukiela
and myself based on nvidia's gamegan
i'll put a link to all this in the
description
but besides this page also the paper
itself
from the initial research this gamecan
research is kind of a step beyond purely
using
gans you know to take key presses and
generate frames there's other things
going on here like static versus dynamic
things
being able to leave an environment and
come back and have the state
remembered so we've kind of just barely
scratched the surface based on what we
did but we were just
just trying to play around so from the
moment i saw
uh the the pacman video
i just i had to play in the environment
i wanted it so bad but the code and the
models and
even the data to train a model was not
really made available for quite some
time and then finally the code came out
but
there were no models or data
so with no data nor model we needed our
own we started off trying to mimic the
open ai gym cart pull environment where
you just balance a pole
on a cart results here started off
questionable
and ended that way too the model had a
hard time learning this one we
thought maybe it was because the point
of the game is to move as little as
possible so the poll
moves as little as possible but later we
thought it might be actually how the bot
played and generated the data for us for
training
so we might wind up revisiting this one
later just to find out the answer to
that question
so we needed something probably a little
more custom suited to our needs and we
didn't really know of any out of the box
environment to use but we did have a
daniel and he proceeded to make a game
that we called vroom
based pretty obviously visually on open
ai's car racing environment but this was
written entirely from scratch for our
specific needs and purpose
but this would be probably a much better
environment since there would always be
movement
and a lot more turning going on and
probably just be easier for
for game gan to understand
so actually training these models is
fairly gpu
memory intensive so we started off
training on the box machines
to rtx 8000s and it went actually okay
i posted some of the preliminary results
to twitter
and this was again like one of the very
first outputs so it's yes it's a little
foggy and grainy and stuff but we're
we are pressing keys the car is turning
even the little wheels are turning
uh we're very excited to see this it let
us know that we are indeed
on the right track pun intended so then
a couple of days later after some
further training i posted the following
results
the pavement sort of moves a little bit
the grass sort of moves a little bit
we're definitely still improving a lot
less fogginess
we can leave the track we can turn
around come back on the track the wheels
are still
turning we could even we go pretty far
off track then turn around and come back
to the same track so that was really
cool and
overall we were just really ecstatic to
see this again this is
this is us playing inside of a neural
network's environment
it is dictating where the road is all
the pixel values the turning
everything is dictated by this neural
network so this is just
i don't know it's just so cool to see so
around this time and video reached out
and
suggested that possibly i could check
out their new dgx station a 180
gigabytes
which has four of the a 180 gigabyte
cards for a total of 320
gigabytes of vram so it became clear
that hey we could
we could maybe take this a step further
so the question became
okay what is the next reasonable step
that we could take from here
and of course as you probably could
guess the next reasonable step was
modeling grand theft auto 5. i came up
with the name
gan theft auto and basically
with a name like that it really can't
fail
so we just needed a lot of data and as
quickly as possible i wasn't going to
have the dgx station for
forever so we needed to figure out how
to make the best of the time that we had
and playing gta manually
to collect the data really wasn't going
to be an option because it would take us
months to to get enough so again daniel
stepped in to bend
gta to his will and created a
rules-based ai
to drive around gta and collect the data
but again time was still an issue
so not just one as many as we could fit
so here we have 12ai all driving around
in the same game instance
and actually on the same stretch of road
they're all here together
it's just the other cars are invisible
and clipping through each other so here
you can see with all the cars visible
uh what's going on
so once we had a good helping of data to
train with we trained our first model
and here's the result after six epochs
of training so
while this is indeed very pixelated this
is very clearly
grand theft auto 5. you can see the
action in the upper left this is the
live key presses as i play the game in
real time notably we also see shadows of
the car
light reflections on the back window and
even the background
moves as we turn things are looking
really impressive so impressive that i
was like okay i guess we gotta ratchet
this up even further
the first model that we trained didn't
include any real boundaries so
in the actual training data we didn't
hit walls or anything like that
so if you drove into a wall in the
inference
the model would just get very confused
very fast but in theory gamegan
should be able to learn these hard
boundaries and how to properly react
when hitting something like a wall or
this like barrier on the highway
given our successes up to this point
along with adding colliding into walls
we thought why not also add
other cars including some collisions
even with those we thought it was
probably best to keep the number of
types of cars minimal so we went with
just police cars and daniel once again
went to work showing gta
who was boss by figuring out how to
spawn in police cars
but this wasn't without some struggle
but eventually daniel continued with his
gta 5
domination and we were back on track
with some more
training data and this is what created
our latest
gann theft auto model which is what you
saw in the beginning though of course
this is still quite a bit more pixelated
so what's the difference
the difference is super sampling so this
is the initial output from the model
and then some quick initial training
steps
and then the rest of the training in
much quicker succession
so this is actually one of the 30
super sampling models that we ended up
training this is just the one that we
ended up choosing as
what we thought was the best looking one
of them all
this is times 8 super sampling so pretty
considerable super sample going on here
so it's pretty impressive considering
the base image that we had to
start from this is the original image
and this is the up-sampled version of
that so that's a
pretty considerable change
altogether we have at least our first
version of
gan theft auto completed some things to
note that i think are
pretty cool or the wall collisions did
eventually
work to the point at least where the car
approaches the wall hits the wall
and then is like forced you know to turn
straight and and kind of
uh slide against the wall so i think
that modeling of physics is actually
kind of cool we didn't really know if
that would work or not and it turns out
it would
so that was pretty neat to see other
things are like the
window sun reflections like we already
kind of pointed out and just the general
lighting
of the area around where the sun is so
it's not just the window you can
actually see
that the sunlight hitting that kind of
matte finish on the car
is also being modeled and it moves as
the car moves
that is that's just so cool and
uh along the lines of this kind of light
casting and all that you also have the
car's shadow and again this shadow works
as you would expect so again these are
kind of like
physics concepts that aren't really cool
you know or impressive in your typical
video game these days but the fact that
a
neural network model is doing this and
doing it pretty accurately
uh is i think pretty impressive to to
see that it's doing all these dynamic
things so
another thing that it's doing is in the
earlier models this wasn't happening and
then i don't know exactly which model so
just like we trained like 30 super
samplers we trained
quite a few game gan models to try to
get you know improve results and so on
and uh in one of the later models i
noticed that
wow as you travel along the road the
background
so the mountains and stuff in the
background actually
is coming closer to you just at the
correct pace
right um again this is really cool i
just i
never expected that that would be
modeled um at all
but it but it was and it like just
really blew me away
like that we were able to um again just
have this neural network model
model that because yeah that's that's
not really impressive and your
traditional kind of game engine in an
environment that you might build with
3d environments are very well advanced
but in terms of
doing this with a neural network model
um
but that's really cool um
another neat thing is just the vehicle
roll so when you turn you know the
horizon kind of rolls a little bit so
it's you know
obviously we're looking at this car in
third person but in grand theft auto
when you kind of turn the car
it gives you you know as you're playing
the perspective that the car
kind of rolls a little bit it's just
this little subtle detail
but again this was picked up by the gan
theft auto model here
and it worked quite well so overall i
think
i think it did really well here i mean
this is definitely
grand theft auto 5. only it's completely
generated for us
by an ai and we get to play within it
and that is just incredibly awesome
to me our training data only consisted
of a small section
of that highway we never actually found
any limitation there in terms of how big
the roam range
could be i would have liked to try
uh training on a much larger range or
just you know just incrementally
increase it
so that we could find what what is the
roaming range here like how big of an
environment could we model
uh before maybe we have to make the
model bigger make some changes and so on
so we really don't know
um i would have liked to have tested
that along with doing more work on car
collisions and just
having other cars work we had a pretty
hard time with that
so so more work there for sure but i
definitely think adding a bigger roaming
range was kind of a low-hanging fruit
that we just didn't have time to do
on the topic of vehicles and vehicle
collisions we had fairly interesting
results including one example where the
gann handled a collision with a police
car by simply splitting
the police car into two for the most
part the model is clearly confused and
fuzzy with what to do with cars often
just simply disappearing them but there
were examples where we could interact
with other cars
somewhat correctly so here you can see
two windows the left is the default gan
theft auto output the right is an up
sample
you can see the live key presses at the
top left of that gan output window
and you can see here how we're unable to
turn through the other car when it is in
the way despite trying to
go left we continue to just kind of be
dragged along
straight we can even see that the police
car rotates a bit if i hit it
closer to the rear wheel the you know
pit maneuver doesn't complete but we can
see it's starting to go in the correct
direction
but eventually the police car just
disappears all together
i think there's probably a lot more that
could be done here and arguably
you know we really only worked on this
project for maybe like a total of two
months
put together and cumulatively and
neither of us came to this knowing much
at all about working with gans so
overall
um i'm super pleased with with our
outcome here
but i definitely think there's a lot of
more interesting things that
can happen here and i mean i kind of
think there's no reason
that we won't have a future where many
game engines
are entirely or even mostly ai based
like this or even things like operating
systems or in other programs
i even have some like real life
simulating that i would like to test
with this kind of model structure maybe
call it mvgan or some something other
than gamegan
so maybe stay tuned for that at some
point but but things like
modeling physics so like this model
learned to model
grand theft autos modeled physics
but could it have just as well learned
to model
maybe some basics uh some basic real
life
physics that would be really cool
because
video game physics is kind of one of
those areas that we are kind of weak at
so anyways lots of cool things and maybe
stay tuned for
some irl gan or something like that
a huge thank you to nvidia for putting
the research out there and also lending
us the awesome dgx station
to help us do the r d at like
warp speed and finally like me like i
said i'm sure that many of you will wish
to play with the models that we've we've
got here we're going to be hosting the
base scan theft auto model
um so the one that i'm actually playing
here along with
the super sampler we really made no
effort to make this run
super efficiently in inference so your
mileage
may vary in the frame rate that you're
able to actually get but i think many of
you will be capable of playing
uh the current version so there will be
a link in the description
to the github and the models and some
basic
training data for you guys to try your
own models if you want the full training
data set
is a bit large for me to uh host
but if you can train something that
looks promising share it with us we'd
probably be happy to to train it for you
on the full data set so if you do have
something interesting uh feel free to
reach out to us
anyway that is all for now i hope you
all found this as
fascinating as we did and maybe more on
this concept
to come in the future if you guys want
to see more of it thanks for watching
and
until next time
you